[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
de la tnt tout de suite voici les titres
de l'actualité à la veille du 20e
anniversaire de l'explosion de l'usiné
azf à toulouse qui fit trente et une
victimes le commandant des opérations de
secours de l'époque revient sur cette
journée apocalyptique avec nos confrères
de la dépêche dans un instant le vaccin
anti qu'ovide continue de faire débat si
bordeaux a été choisie pour tester ses
effets secondaires à chamois
l'orgueilleux près d'epinal c'est un
autre son de cloche que vous verrez la
commune se retrouve son médecin car
celui ci refuse de se faire vacciner
depuis le début de l'année douze mille
migrants ont tenté la traversée de la
manche une situation qui tend un peu
plus les relations entre paris et
londres
reportage de wéo la chaîne de la voix du
nord et puis dans ce journal également
les deux youtuber mcfly et carlito qui
ont récolté des fonds au profit du
sauvetage en mer en réalisant un exploit
la traversée de la méditerranée à la
rame
nous démarrons ce journal en partant
pour toulouse avec un bien triste
anniversaire 31 morts 20 mille blessés
c'est le triste bilan d'une des plus
grosses catastrophes industrielles du
siècle il ya presque vingt ans l'usiné
azf explosait alors que les
circonstances du drame restent encore
floues agnès grimaldi et clément gaci de
la dépêche du midi nos partenaires sur
place ont rencontré christian pizzo
carreau le commandant des opérations de
secours de l'époque et vous allez voir
il n'est pas près d'oublier ce 21
septembre
2007 photo pour moi résume
résume tout l'atypisme d'azf déjà le
ciel avant leur explosion de ciel était
bleu là c'est un gris c'est et puis bien
entendu ce que ce centre de la photo là
où on voit deux blessés également cette
atypisme ces deux personnes représentent
les centaines de blessés qui étaient sur
le secteur et qui refluaient sur le
centre de toulouse et quand j'allais sur
azf ont marre et et on me demandait num
militari de porter secours aux blessés
mais je ne le pouvais pas parce que ma
fonction était pas celle là ma fonction
c'est de voir ce qui se passe de
comprendre et d'organiser donc à partir
de là ça c'était mon fils rouges avec
plus aucun repère retour donc je me
devais de me focaliser sur ce que
j'étais sûre qu'est ce qu'elle était ma
mission pour réagir et organiser le plus
tôt possible et le mieux possible
j'entendais parler du pot ce traumatisme
tout ça
j'imaginais pas que le temps ne
penserait pas tout ça quoi mais non
c'est comme ça
vous savez depuis le 15 septembre
dernier certains professionnels sont
obligés de se faire vacciner pour
pouvoir continuer à travailler le
médecin de charmoille orgueilleux à 25
kilomètres d'epinal lui a refusé de se
payer à cette injonction et s'est donc
vue contrainte de fermer son cabinet
pour le soutenir et éviter de se
retrouver dans un désert médical des
habitants ont lancé une pétition une
histoire racontée par anthony sap et de
neil etienne pour vosges télévision
regarder une banderole au centre du
village un rassemblement devant l'unique
cabinet médical de la commune tous ces
gens sont des patients du docteur baina
charmoille orgueilleux entre epinal et
d'art n'est venu le soutenir parce que
le médecin refuse de se vacciner contre
le coc vide et que par conséquent à
partir du 15 septembre selon la loi il
ne pourra plus exercer les vaccins j'ai
toujours vacciner je suis très pro avec
ça
la preuve le dernier avec sa donc qui
est pour le peuple papillomavirus chez
les garçons j'avais déjà commencé à le
faire donc il n'est pas question d'être
anti vaxgen estimé que pour moi je
n'avais pas une balance bénéfices
risques qui était suffisante par rapport
aux bénéfices pour recevoir cette
injection pendant encore une semaine le
dr bail ne peut multiplier les tests de
dépistage et continuèrent à travailler
au contact des patients mais à partir du
15 septembre le processus vaccinale
devraient être enclenchée pour être
validé au plus tard le 15 octobre dans
le cas contraire s il reçoit toujours
des patients l' agence régionale de
santé et le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins
vont intervenir clairement la loi dit
qu'il faut être vaccinés nous ne sommes
pas là pour interpréter la loi reprend
donc la pause donc nous on nous
demandera de veiller à ce qu'elle soit
respectée au niveau de la position
médicale il est clair maintenant que le
bénéfice risque de la vaccination penche
vraiment en faveur de la vaccination
n'est pas sans risque il ya eu des
accidents puis on ne peut pas les
oublier non plus qu'ils ont existé mais
quand on voit le nombre de malades quand
tu n'es pas vacciner et
de vacciner pour les patients du dr bein
en tout cas le problème ce n'est pas le
vaccin certains ont décidé de le faire
d'autres non personne ici ne juge la
décision du médecin leur véritable souci
c'est juste d'avoir un médecin
nous ne nous propose rien du tout un
remplaçant à une permanence deux jours
par semaine je cherchais en arrière les
docteurs alentours pas nous prendre et
on nous répond que si ça va parfois les
urgences j'ai peur pour ma patientèle
j'ai peur pour les malades et plus gras
j'ai peur pour les personnes âgées à
domicile qui peuvent pas se déplacer
officiellement le dr bein est en
vacances jusqu'au 20 septembre il ne
sait pas encore s'il reprendra ensuite
ces consultations sans vaccin au risque
d'être suspendu des situations comme
celle ci serait très rare dans les
vosges le seul autre cas a connu chez
les médecins et celui d'un généraliste
qui aurait opté pour la télémédecine
donc sans contact direct avec les
patients en attendant que la vaccination
ne soit plus obligatoire pour le
personnel soignant nous partons pour la
nouvelle aquitaine maintenant en
décembre l'agencé européenne du
médicament a lancé une étude sur les
effets secondaires de tous les vaccins
contre la copie de 19 dans près de huit
pays et en france c'est bordeaux qui a
été choisie pour faire partie des villes
pilotes de cette étude regardez ce
reportage auprès de la task force qui
s'appelle pharmaco épi un sujet signé
bénédicte 2 1 pour tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest à bordeaux
implantée au méga centres de vaccination
pharmaco et piquante chaque jour
d'inscrire de nouveaux participants à
l'étude evans qu'aux adolescents ou
adultes tous les témoignages compte nous
on attribue essaie de recueillir toutes
ces données et les quantifier les
transmettre aux agences européennes pour
que fassent leur travail d'analysé et 10
bat globalement il ya eu plus de remous
chez les gens vaccinés que les gens pas
vaccinés ou inversement il ya une
moindre rhume c'est les gens d'accéder
que chez gens vaccinés et là du coup on
peut l'agencé urbaine de médicaments
autorités sanitaires vont creuser un peu
pour savoir s'il ya des risques
éventuels liés au vaccin ne peuvent
s'inscrire uniquement les patients qui
viennent de recevoir leur première dose
de vaccin dans un délai de 48 heures
maximum à ce jour l'étude recense plus
de 1000 participants
il ya des enjeux qui sont assez
importants puisque mille personnes ça
peut paraître beaucoup mais il faut
savoir qu'à l'échelle d'une population
ce n'est pas fait on vise au niveau du
territoire national onze nous faire ça
donc on espère que du coup les gens qui
restent à l'actionnaire accepterait de
participer à l'étude une fois inscrit
chaque participant partage ses ressentis
post vaccination des données anonymes
envoyées ici dans ce bâtiment du chu
reste aux équipes de
pharmacoépidémiologie zay avant de les
envoyer à l' agence européenne du
médicament
c'est vraiment un défi au niveau tant
national qu'européen de faire parler la
même langue à tout le monde ce qui se
passe c'est que vous disiez n'importe
quel synonyme de j'ai mal à la tête j'ai
c'est fallait migraine tout ça ça va
être codé de la même manière en local
grâce à un dictionnaire qui s'appelle
m'aidera qui va en fait permettre
d'uniformiser le codage des effets
indésirables donc céphalées en france
sera codée de la même manière qu'un mode
est aux pays-bas c'est dans cette pièce
bien gardé que les serveurs traite 24
heures sur 24 les données des 1000
participants
si quelques similitudes apparaissent il
est encore trop tôt pour tirer des
conclusions alors on est toujours en
train de les analyser parce qu'on peut
pas analyser les 1000 patients seul on
analyse les 1000 patients ou regarde
tout ce qui se passe ailleurs en europe
donc on analyse des données européennes
et donc on est en cours d'analysé on va
regarder ces données ensemble avec
l'agencé européenne du médicament au
niveau européen l'objectif est
d'atteindre les 65 mille participants en
france la barre est fixée à 10 mille
convives toujours en martinique cette
fois ci le virus a des conséquences
inattendues les fleuristes de l'île ont
de plus en plus de mal à
s'approvisionner ils sont également pris
d'assaut par les familles en deuil
notons tout de même que depuis cinq
semaines le nombre de patients testés
positifs est en baisse là bas ce sont
des images de via à tv martinique que
vous voyez sur cet écran dans ce journal
nous partons pour le nord maintenant les
personnes tentant de rejoindre
l'angleterre en traversant la manche
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses cette
année on en dénombre douze mille contre
10000 en 2020 une tension migratoires
qui met à mal les relations
franco-britanniques d'ailleurs à londres
la ministre de l'intérieur menace de
renvoyer certaines embarcations vers la
france les précisions à calais de
caroline fichten de wéo tv la chaîne de
la voix du nord
c'était au début du moins sur la plage
d'ambleteuse des dizaines de migrants
étaient empêchés de prendre la mer une
tentative de traversée avorté donc mais
bien d'autres ont réussi à traverser la
manche sur ce genre d'embarcation c'est
un réel danger alors quand la ministre
de l'intérieur britannique a annoncé
vouloir refouler les migrants en mer qui
arriverait dans les eaux anglaises ça
fait bondir les associations
cet idéal paraît complètement délirante
donc après avoir si c'est juste un effet
de communication politique en fait pour
peut être capté de l'électorat l'extrême
droite ou si c'est vraiment ça va être
suivies d'effets concrets ce qui paraît
surprenant en fait dans le sens où ce
que demande priti patel c'est quelque
chose d'illégal en fait il ya des droits
en mer et puis quand on y repousser des
bateaux dont bic à des gens sur ces
bateaux en fait ça veut dire qu'on
repousse et un bateau et après quoi il a
plus d'essence en fait les gens on les
abandonne au milieu de la manche face à
ça n'a pas de sens les départs pour les
traversées semble se faire davantage
dans le boulot n'est plus au sud donc
malgré cela les camps restent
majoritairement à calais où les exilés
sont environ 1500 la maire de la ville
dénonce les propos de la ministre
britannique et demande une nouvelle fois
la renégociation des accords du touquet
et la création d'un comité
interministériel sur la problématique
migratoire
au bout du compte on subit donc on est
dans l'impuissance on y met des moyens
et nîmes et des cours moyens mais ce
n'est pas suffisant et donc aujourd'hui
on est une ville frontière donc on peut
faire mieux et voilà j'attends en tous
les cas que cette proposition puisse
être accepté la problématique migratoire
a calé n'est pas nouvelle elle a plus de
20 ans ces tentatives de traversée par
la mer sont plus récentes des traversées
dangereuses et qui se paie les exilés
avec moins de ressources continuent de
tenter leur chance en grimpant à bord
des camions
tout à fait autre chose maintenant cette
semaine une soixantaine de communes du
gard a été touchée par les inondations
et mardi dernier gérald darmanin était
sur place dans la commune de bernis
l'occasion pour le ministre de
l'intérieur de déclarer l'état de
catastrophe naturelle je vous propose de
l'écouter au micro de via occitanie sur
place
afin que ces communes de plus rapidement
possible puisque pour elle même comme
pour leurs concitoyens ou pour le monde
économique sans valoir les assurances et
qu'ils ne soient pas en plus des
difficultés qu'ils connaissent
aujourd'hui d'inondations qui ne soit
pas concernée par des lenteurs
administratives j'appellerai dès demain
matin la présidente de la fédération des
assurances également tout à fait autre
chose dans l'actualité maintenant
emmanuel macron le président de la
république ne cesse de répéter et mais
la prose de jean giono c'est donc tout
naturellement de passage à manosque que
le président de la république a visité
sa maison en compagnie de sylvie durée
de giono la fille de l'écrivain une
visite que les caméras de la provence
dont confrères sur place on peut suivre
pour nous regarder
suivez pas infinies ta phrase mine aussi
par atteindre 6000 quand tu partiras je
reprendrai je relirai ma trace je
terminerais vu en fusion
et quelquefois le soir quand il a fini
ses trois pages et deux enfants je
prends plus est s'ils avaient fini la
matinée la journée mais quelquefois
quand est arrivé le soir mallié finition
s'approche était pas terminée la
terminer par un tropisme
il attendait lendemain matin ils étaient
censés c'est presque un sucre d'orge
pour moi le plaisir de revenir de
phrases et ensuite du jeu le plaisir
d'un continent
et puis tout à fait autre chose pour nos
amis biker qui regardent le grand jt des
territoires direction ecommoy en sarthe
pour une escale du tour de france en
motos anciennes nous allons rencontrer
didier et annie belles dents qui
organise l'accueil de cette étape depuis
bientôt trois ans devant la caméra de
margaux bianco de lmtv sarthe leurs
émotions reste palpable regardez
découvrir la france à 50 km c'est
l'identité même du tour de france à
motos anciennes l'itinéraire change à
chaque édition cette année les 49 moto
sélectionné parcours près de quatre
mille bornes en dix neuf états alors le
tour de france a beau torrentielles fait
escale à eco roi parce que leur faisons
le circuit qu'avaient fait nos aînés il
y a trente ans il ya trente ans et sont
passés un peu plus loin quelques mois et
comme nous organisons les étapes avec
leurs membres avec les participants nous
avons la chance d'avoir un couple qui
fait le tour de france bédié des cobras
ce couple c'est didier anies belle dans
les seuls participants en tandem du
cortège pour leur troisième
participation au tour cette escale à
ecommoy et toute particulière on était
un petit peu stressé ce matin lorsque
on avait organisé un peu l'étape de ce
soir est donc la réception et donc on
voulait de là les premiers pour voir si
tout était au point donc on est parti
très tôt ce matin on a roulé que tous
les deux pour gagner de temps
très ému
le public en faisant après midi
l'arrivée du monde
sur leurs ces mecs de 1951 le confort
est rudimentaire c'est l'une des règles
de cette manifestation qui n'accepte que
des motos d'avant 1954 mais par passion
la seule passagère du tour s'en
accommode c'est très confortable j'ai
pas du tout peiné pendant tout le
périple eu jusqu'à maintenant et là il
reste plus que quatre étapes donc je
pense que ça devrait bien se passer
cette soirée d'escale à ecommoy est
aussi une aubaine pour le tourisme on
essaie bien sûr de communiquer sur la
commune sur le canton sur le département
pour faire savoir que bien c'est une
région où on peut aussi y voir de belles
choses et aussi bien faire des activités
tout à fait intéressante puisqu'on a là
des motards qui viennent de la france
entière ça peut être aussi
source de d'idées de sorties de tourisme
pour d'autres motards
les motards sont arrivés à dol de
bretagne ce mercredi il ne leur reste
que 4 et 500 kilomètres à parcourir
jusqu'au samedi 11 septembre
le café voilà une boisson qui fait des
adeptes c'est la boisson la plus bue du
monde 94 % d'entre nous en consomment
régulièrement mais pour satisfaire les
amateurs il faut des torréfacteurs et
des bons comme eric maignan un habitant
d'ille-et-vilaine qu'a rencontré tvr
notre chaîne partenaire à rennes
dernière dégustation avant le grand
départ eric maignan et torréfacteur
depuis maintenant quatre ans ce week end
à paris il va se mesurer aux plus grands
en participant au concours du meilleur
mélange expresso de france
c'est ma curiosité me comparé par
rapport aussi aux meilleurs ouvriers de
france où on est en face de moi qui ont
plus d'expérience que moi c'est aussi ça
va me permettre à tous d'apprendre très
fort l'art du café et riscle a appris
tout seul dans son garage il a lancé son
activité à domloup qu'il a appelé la
brûlerie du castel chaque mois il livre
jusqu'à 400 kg de café à une centaine de
bars et restaurants pour ce week end
eric à confectionner durant deux mois
cette combinaison de trois arabica et
tout se joue à la cuisson un travail de
parcimonie qui commence dès le choix du
grain ont même salé capé en sache c'est
pareil on regarde si un petit grain vers
un écrin qu'est pas qu on enlève voilà
c'est vraiment ça que que nous les
petits artisans on plaide et ça se
retrouve aussi dans la tasse après cran
face à lui une quinzaine de candidats le
résultat du concours sera annoncé lundi
sans transition et ce week-end ce sont
les journées du patrimoine
l'occasion de visiter ou de revisiter
pour certains d'entre vous les trésors
français or parmi ces joyaux certains
summer malheureusement alors pour
collecter des fonds nécessaires à cette
rénovation des monuments et a été lancée
par la française des jeux un jeu à
gratter d'ailleurs qui s'appelle mission
patrimoine parmi les bénéficiaires le
manoir de kernault dit à plouénan dans
le finistère visite des lieux par le
très heureux vous allez le voir
propriétaire un reportage de valérie
leroux coléno de tébéo la chaîne de
complot télégramme sur place
c'est en se baladant en famille que ce
normand découvre il y a plus de dix ans
et cheminées qui dépassait d'un énorme
mur avec dulière à tour et de de ronces
et géo lieu voir un petit plus ce que
c'était un ancien manoir du xviiie
siècle avec vue sur la rivière de
morlaix illica lot
en 2014 en partie puis en totalité en
2018 il en fait l'acquisition
aujourd'hui seul le petit pavillon et
rénové ainsi que l'ancienne cuisine du
château mais elle est restée elle
comment dire très aéré quant à l'est
l'ouest c'est la partie qui est la plus
urgente à reprendre avant qu'elle ne
s'écroule complètement au moins
stabiliser la maçonnerie sens qu'au
début faut pas trop regarder le coût
financier faut y aller petit à petit
parce que sinon se découragent la
famille a déjà investi plus de 400000
euros pour donner une nouvelle vie à ce
bâtiment alors être sélectionné par la
mission stéphane bern
surprise inespérée des travaux je leur
ai remis facilement à dans dix ans on
pouvoir avoir lieu dans deux ans pour la
fondation du patrimoine qui a proposé la
candidature de kerlaudy celui ci remplit
tous les critères de sélection et
bâtiments visibles de la voie publique
il n'est pas inscrit à l'inventaire et
donc qui ne reçoit pas dead on labellise
que dans la mesure où les gens
reconstitue le bâtiment tel qu'il était
à l'origine c'est vraiment de les
encourager ça peut être cinquante mille
euros comme ça peut être plus tout
dépend évidemment du loto soutenir le
patrimoine privé ou public c'est aussi
pour la fondation la promesse de
soutenir toute une filière dans la
région ça va faire travailler des
artisans des pays maintenir le
savoir-faire
trois autres sites ont été récemment
sélectionné dans la région l'église de
pontrieux dans les côtes d'armor celle
du verger en ille et vilaine et le
manoir de la cour delaunay dans le
morbihan depuis 2000 18 27 projets
bretons ont bénéficié du soutien de la
mission patrimoine et 31 millions
d'euros reversés
en ile-de-france maintenant chaque année
ce n'est pas moins de 1149 facteurs qui
sillonne les routes du département des
yvelines pour délivrer colis et lettres
il ya un arthus-bertrand a décidé de
rendre hommage à ces hommes et femmes en
bleu et en jaune en lançant un projet
appelé portrait de france par les
facteurs les facteurs qui l'acceptent
peuvent prendre en photo les clients
emblématiques de leur tournée c'est un
reportage de tv 78 dans les yvelines et
donc
il est 14h30 à la poste marly le roy et
claude s'engage dans une tournée
particulière aujourd'hui il ne faudra
pas que distribuer le courrier à ses
clients il va aussi les prendre en photo
cela fait un an que claude est facteur
et pourtant comme beaucoup d'autres il
connaît déjà tous les habitants des rues
qu'il arpente quotidiennement alors face
à cette proximité il ya un arthus
bertrand et la poste ont invité tous les
facteurs de france a photographié les
français qui les touche dans le cadre de
leur tournée claude n'a pas hésité à
participer c'est la première fois que
l'on propose à des facteurs de prendre
effectivement un appareil photo de
pouvoir rentrer quelque part dans cette
intimité que la plupart des français ne
voient pas c'est à dire de s'intéresser
aux gens de les prendre en photo et de
leur poser des questions et au delà du
métier que nous avons et que nous aimons
c'est pour nous un véritable panorama
pour vous de découvrir comment nous
sommes au quotidien toujours le sourire
aux lèvres il tire le portrait des
différentes personnes qu'ils rencontrent
toutes heureuses de se prêter au jeu
l'occasion aussi d'en apprendre un peu
plus sur ces visages qu'il côtoie
quotidiennement qu'est ce que tu vas
voir
c'est aussi la très large actuellement
au jour d'aujourd'hui ce que j'aimerais
voir
c'est plutôt une baisse de l'intolérance
mon facteur je le croise tous les jours
et donc c'est vraiment une relation
personnelle avec lui il me connaît on se
connaît la relation de proximité est
importante parce que on ne peut que
mieux servir son client quand on connait
je peux avoir des personnes qui ont des
recommandés avec des bonnes des
mauvaises nouvelles mais le facteur est
le facteur toujours souriant un lien
unique qui ni une profession humaines et
celles et ceux qu'ils inspirent ou les
me mets moi je suis facteur et tous mes
clients je les aime les photos
recueillies seront présentés à travers
une exposition digital d'ici la fin 2021
et les plus belles photos seront
exposées à la poste du louvre l'année
prochaine voilà connaissez vous ce nom
michel ocelot et bien c'est le
réalisateur de films d'animation tels
que kirikou et la sorcière princes et
princesses ou encore azur et asmar est
bien plus de 400 oeuvres du
septuagénaire ont été réunis dans une
exposition à annecy que nous allons
visiter grâce à victoria lopez pour 8
mont blanc qui a suivi le cinéaste dans
sa déambulation regarder
une malencontreuse chute l'a empêchée
d'assister en juin dernier à
l'inauguration de cette exposition
michel ocelot découvre enfin en ce mois
de septembre le travail réalisé par les
musées d'annecy c'est vraiment un
hommage que comme oran et vocal jeu si
sensible et qui pourrait me rassurer au
cas où j'aurais eu des doutes sur mesac
laurent plissement ne fait que ça se
passe à annecy c'est le meilleur endroit
pour moi
annecy et le festival d'animation a été
ma bouée de sauvetage et ma ma bouffée
d'oxygène pendant
très longtemps depuis le 4 juin les
visiteurs se pressent pour découvrir la
vie et l'oeuvre du créateur de kirikou
plusieurs salles rassemble des objets et
des documents inédits prêtés pour la
plupart par l'artiste lui-même et qui
nous font entrer au coeur de sa création
on voit que l'oeuvre de michel ocelot a
vraiment touché tous les âges on a des
personnes âgées des enfants des familles
des adolescents des étudiants en art qui
viennent aussi pour voir le travail
de michel ocelot donc un public très
varié et des très bons retours on est
ravi en même temps on est s'est passé on
peut dire qu'on est surpris parce que
vraiment le travail de michel ocelot il
a touché tellement de gens il est que ça
soit les films de silhouettes que ce
soit kirikou azur et azmar que je pense
que que
découvrir céder ses dessins découvrir sa
manière de travailler et aussi découvrir
d'autres facettes de michel ocelot et
est quelque chose de très intéressant
pour le public de ses débuts difficiles
à son lien avec le festival d'annecy en
passant par la génèse de ses plus grands
long métrage l'exposition michel ocelot
artificiers de l'imaginaire est à
découvrir jusqu'au 11 octobre au musée
château d'annecy
tout à fait autre chose maintenant je
vous le disais dans les titres les deux
youtube earth mcfly et carlito sont
aussi à l'aise à l'elysée que dans l'eau
il a réalisé un véritable exploit en
reliant le continent à la corse à la
rame une mission pour récolter des dons
au profit des sauveteurs en mer un
événement immortalisé par les caméras
devient telle est pas aisé nos confrères
partenaires sur place encore se
regardent
et une récolte de fonds qui a organisé
les fonds doivent être remis à la snsm
pourquoi ce choix déjà ces entreprises
qui plaît énormément garçons par leur
reste la réaction là il seulement deux
personnes qui sont mes de la mer et qui
aurait besoin de peut-être ces gens là
s'il avait eu le moindre souci pour les
accompagner la récolte a très bien
avancé puisque a dépassé le cas des
10000 euros quasiment même plus que ça
et on a pas le compte exact master si ça
va être divisé à toutes les toutes les
stations de la snsm et pour finir ce
journal quelques images du concert donné
au profit de la tanière un zorro refuge
situé en eure et loir je suis pietri
jean luc lahaye
ou encore zouk machine se sont succédé
sur la scène dans le but de récolter des
fonds pour ce lieu un peu à part plus
qu'un zoo un refuge c'est un véritable
oasis pour les 600 pensionnaires qui ont
tous vécu des épisodes douloureux dans
leur vie et qui ont besoin de se
remettre sur pattes
c'est le cas de le dire voilà vous
pouvez aider ce refuge la tanière en
leur adressant des dons sur l'adresse
qui apparaît sur cet écran c'est la fin
de ce grand jt des territoires merci de
nous avoir suivi sur vos chaînes de la
tnt et sur tv5 monde on se retrouve bien
sûr pour une nouvelle édition très
prochainement d'ici là bon courage à
tous au revoir
[Musique]